alright as hoc Smollett hate-crime hoax
plot thickens well the state's attorney
Kim Fox is taking a lot of heat from
Chicago police for what seems to be a
gross miscarriage of justice they are
very angry today and Tracy Callard joins
us from our West Coast newsroom with the
very latest tres chaud talked about
mounting pressure the associations for
every police chief in every Chicago
suburb have given Kim Fox a vote of
no-confidence and today demanded her
resignation Fox's handling of the
justice Millette case was the final
straw
but police are also irate over her
refusing to prosecute low-level felonies
like burglary and shoplifting under 100
or under $1,000
police say theft is now permissible in
Chicago Kim Fox though issued a
statement saying quote I was elected by
the people of Cook County to pursue
community safety prevent harm and uphold
the values of fairness and equal justice
I'm proud of my record in doing that and
I plan to do so through the end of my
term and if the people so will it into
the future and Chicago's newly elected
mayor Lori Lightfoot says Fox owes the
public a better explanation of what
happened in the justice Millette case
because the evidence against him was
quote compelling that's a bold statement
because Lightfoot was herself a former
federal prosecutor and the former
Chicago Mayor Rahm Emanuel gave justice
Millette until today to pay $130,000
fine to help cover the cost of the
investigation there has been no payment
the city is now planning to sue
jussie Smollett Frank trace Gallagher in
a West Coast newsroom thank you tonight